así es el presidente de donald trump
continuará con sus funciones desde que
se trasladó desde la casa blanca al
hospital walter y también tenía en esta
digamos su habitación presidencial una
oficina en donde continuó trabajando
contigo hablando con senadores en el
congreso republicanos y se espera que el
presidente continúe con sus actividades
de hecho este mensaje que envió hacía
referencia a lo mismo asegurando que no
se debía tener miedo al virus que se
tenía que regresar a sus funciones y que
también quería agradecer a las personas
que habían estado siguiendo su salud
permanentemente y vimos como el
presidente salió caminando afuera del
hospital y después fue trasladado a la
casa blanca hasta el momento el personal
médico no ha confirmado por cuánto
tiempo estará la primera dama en el
hospital quien no acompañó al presidente
pero lo cierto es que el personal médico
de walter y al igual que el médico
personal del presidente aseguraron que
no hay ninguna razón que indique en su
estado de salud que no puede continuar
con sus
desde la casa blanca diana y antes de
salir el mandatario envió un mensaje en
twitter diciendo que no le tengan miedo
al coronavirus es que no cambiará su
postura pese a que eeuu es el país más
afectado del mundo
como lo mencionas esto ha generado
muchísimas críticas por parte incluso de
los demócratas al interior del congreso
y justo hace una hora el candidato
demócrata también a la presidencia yo
bailé le pidió al mandatario que apruebe
que dé respaldo a un mandato nacional
para el uso de la máscara para la
luchada y protección de los ciudadanos y
este es un debate que se ha dado al
interior de muchos estados donde
gobernadores republicanos están luchando
para que las personas no utilicen la
máscara y no sea un mandato como tal de
la luz pública así que vemos una
contradicción entre lo que está haciendo
el presidente y lo que dice en su
política